[Music]
let's talk about your hot bod oh my god
you look beautiful you're always
beautiful God every day has to be about
this are you and your man that you go
together
yeah he's changed my entire life he
cooks for me and teaches taught me how
to cook and he taught me how you can
feel better if you eat healthier and
exercise and even mentally like I cuz
after my second surgery I went into this
kind of dark place and he was like want
to workout and I was like no but okay
and now I love it I'm obsessed with it
and I've never felt better
and so what are you doing what's the
like women I'm doing t25 Sean t I love
it so much Sean tt right it's amazing I
bother DVDs I'm obsessed with it what do
you guys have for the holidays
big family parties and my birthday I'm
gonna be 24 so ready meghan trainor has
a lot to celebrate these days the singer
is one of the expert panelists on the
four battled for stardom a new music
competition show premiering January 4th
on Fox I was really excited because it's
brand new and it's not what you've seen
before it's very fresh and the reward is
so amazing how they actually give you an
opportunity to work with people in the
music industry and to have a chance to
be heard on radio that's just a
no-brainer for me that's so cool when
you were first starting out who was your
mentor was there anyone in the business
that you kind of looked up to that was
kind of the first celebrity that was
nice to you and like you got that yeah
Jayla was so nice to me so nice to me he
helped me out yeah she was so kind and
told me to get Pinterest yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]